agents the next hostage we've managed to
track down is Mel Arnold as a
professional writer it's unclear what
Natalia wants with him but he has been
spotted in the Foggy Bottom District of
Washington DC agents get him
[Music]
back before the outbreak of the green
poison melis estblished himself as a
skilled writer releasing non-fiction
literature centered around the green and
sustainable living additionally he
delved into crafting fictional
narratives that embodied those
eco-friendly
principles certain enthusiasts perceived
Mel's writings as a guiding Beacon
offering insights into constructing a
more promising tomorrow a certain fan
Cassandra Reigns exhibited an unstable
Obsession passionately urging Mel to
align with their
cause those who don't recognize this
name Cassandra Reigns was featured in
the division compromise novel where
Reigns would lead a group of
environmental extremists who were dead
set on helping the world repair their
first targets were Texan oil refineries
they want to see the world free from
fossil
fuels however it was these fuels that
were also the lifeline to helping the
truckies Supply various settlements of
survivors with food and
supplies um at Manny have you seen
anyone to check on protus Proteus at the
jtf squad you sent to Kenley College
last week we haven't heard from them in
3 days that's not right I didn't send
anyone to keny college well someone did
they took a mobile shade server with
them and they should be in contact with
your agents you really haven't heard
anything I'm sorry no I haven't heard
anything about Kenley College what's the
name of the squad leader Jack Arnold and
what's your name Mel Arnold Jack your
brother my wife okay thanks Mel I'll see
what I can
do where's Jack I'm sorry we haven't
heard anything back from the team well
then send another team to get them we
don't have those kind of resources then
find them I wish I could either you
value your people or you don't you don't
just send people on a mission and then
leave them to die especially not someone
like Jack we're doing the best we can
you mean the division I'm sorry but we
can't just send agents on a wild goose
chase to the middle of nowhere you've
got a helicopter you've got a location
you've got a Target Proteus you're
missing jtf Squad that is not a wild
goose chase Manny agents choose their
missions ultimately it's not up to me
I'm just a coordinator but you decide if
they know she's missing you decide what
missions agents know about don't pretend
there isn't power and responsibility in
that Jack is jtf you used to be jtf
you're not division Manny you have the
power to bring our girl home if you
decide to give a [__] about the people
and not the
mission is a quick refresher task force
Proteus was a jtf squad that was
established to scaven any supplies that
could find in DC after several weeks the
Convoy came across Kenley College Jack
decided to investigate the campus to see
what they could find but would end up
getting ambushed by the
outcasts the outcasts killed 99% of the
jtf in the Convoy and looted the
supplies including military grade
servers encrypted radio handsets
chemicals explosives a jtf engineer and
a mobile shd
server you wanted to see me thank you
for coming M what do you want Manny to
apologize you're right I forgot where I
came from I got too focused on the big
picture I started to forget about the
people I'm responsible for thank
you any update on Jack
yes
Mel are you serious Manny sent his
agents to get me are you hurt I'll be
fine what the hell happened Outcast
followed us to the college I thought I
cost you me too let's get you cleaned up
thank you
Manny as Manny rebuilds the castle
sement he recruits the United Mel and
Jack to run food production and
storage you look happy what's wrong
nothing's wrong just had a meeting with
Manny about reclaiming the castle we're
going to set up some long-term food
security there a farm and storage
seriously yeah you're not worried you're
going to get bored frankly I invite
boring you want you want us to find a
job on the farm for you could be fun
getting your hands dirty I'm good kind
of trying to keep my hands clean and not
take on too much sounds like someone has
been talking to Billings I can neither
confirm nor deny that his sessions are
helping I kind of hate that they're
helping it's okay to admit that you need
help and it's super okay to admit that
therapy helps it's not therapy just
counseling
whatever helps you sleep at night
sweetie if you need a new laptop we
recovered a case of them from odia vix
lead Pann out I still can't believe
we're working with that guy I thought he
was such an [__] oh he's he's still
an [__] but now he's a helpful
[__] he's our [__] can y'all stop
calling me an [__] you know I can
hear you
right
agents receive Intelligence on Mel's
possible location at the taxi graveyard
in the Foggy Bottom District of
Washington DC they mobilized quickly and
find The Outpost heavily defended by
true Sun
soldiers once the hostiles were cleared
and the compound secured it quickly
became evident that Mel was no longer on
site it was at that moment that agent
Johnson suddenly announced the increase
of Black Tusk activity at the greenhouse
the agents redirect their focus and set
off towards the southern side of the
district
proceeding through the front door the
building looks abandoned however once
they had made it through to the
Courtyard several true Suns could be
seen dotted around the agents quickly
maneuver through the courtyard and engag
the true Suns it was clear that there
were more than just a few hostiles on
site but fortunately the agents had
brought along their new toy the
orus they never really stood a chance
after climbing another flight of stairs
they eventually come face to face with a
black task high value Target once
eliminated a hostile comms was
[Music]
intercepted hostile radio
intercepted you okay Mill uh yeah yeah I
just need to rest uh we should be safe
at Navy
Hill you heard him agent get to Navy
Hill
got agents swiftly Converge on the
compound the true suns have fortified
the area but the agents undeterred
navigate the barricades and overcome
wave after wave of hostile
forces their perseverance pays off as
they successfully neutralize two
prominent leaders within the true Suns
ranks now hostile radio
intercepted hello is anyone there
they're keeping me Columbia Plaza agent
if you can hear this please get me the
hell out of
here
[Music]
agents confront Fierce resistance from
the true Suns upon arriving at the
entrance of the Columbia Plaza
broadcast with determination they
navigate the structure eliminating all
hostiles they
encounter eventually they would face off
against a true Sun leader once
eliminated Johnson's voice would once
again be heard over the air
pieces he tracked Mel Arnold to
Roosevelt Island I have no idea why
sooba would take in
there diving straight in there the
agents waste no time charging on
Roosevelt Island Mel is a civvy they
never should have been put in this
position as they delve deeper into the
facility waves of enemies grow in size
and intensity you're
mine pushing through the compound
eliminating kless hostiles and another
enemy communication would be intercepted
passing
grenade hostile radio
intercepted you need anything fertilizer
maybe the crops look
hungry
crops the agents continue their
Relentless Advance battling through room
after room facing a horde of true Sun
soldiers but the agents are undeterred
making precise shots and effortlessly
dispatching enemies left and right as
they push deeper into the the island
they finally come face to face with the
formidable true Sun leader who joins the
fight except when I say face to face I
actually mean he was miles away and when
I say formidable I actually didn't even
know it was a leader he just died really
fast but you get the
point area
secure what the HSE going on that's what
I'd like to know agent meet us back at
the
castle
oh I can't believe you took the time to
find me I'm impressed Manny would make
the effort I'm just a farmer now I guess
he hasn't forgotten the jtf and the
division are supposed to work for the
people after
all no have you seen Agent Johnson no
why I wanted to talk to him about the
recruiter wor are the issues with a
mobile shade server connected somehow
I'm fine no lingering Trauma from being
kidnapped by the Black Tusk thank you
for asking sorry how are you good you
know apparently still your conscience
and I need to remind you to stop
focusing on the conspiracy that isn't
there and instead focus on the people in
front of you that you have volunteered
to keep safe yeah you're right you're
right I just I can't believe I lost them
you got them back I saw Mari she looks
great seemed pissed at you but she
looked great yeah I'm working on fixing
things there too maybe you should stop
trying to fix things and just do your
job go get our people back so you talked
to marray I did but I want to talk to
Jack do your job and get my wife back
again like all of the others Manny
catches up with me after he is safely
brought home to the castle somewhat
annoyingly Manny is once again been told
by Mel that he needs to focus on the
people in front of him not the large
Mission at play I understand if his job
is just to look after the settlements
especially the castle settlement this
should be his main concern but he is
currently still a coordinator for the
division the bigger picture around the
recruiter soov the Black Tusk and Kelvin
mcmanis absolutely should be at the
Forefront of his mind with Murray and
his future family Maybe it's time for
many to step down as the coordinator and
for someone who isn't quite so close and
emotionally invested in the people
within the settlement to take over and
keep the division moving towards the
bigger
[Music]
goals maybe I'm just sick of all the
guilt trip smell was spouting throughout
this one on top of the way Mario's
treating him but I legitimately think
that man's time as our coordinator
should be over and done with for now he
needs to figure out where his priorities
are I don't think anyone with think
badly of him choosing to look after his
family and the people around them but
trying to play Both Sides I just don't
think this is working and I can see it
causing more harm than good in the long
run maybe this is why Agent Johnson has
suddenly turned up out of the blue
however I still don't trust his sudden
appearance so we'll see I'm just hoping
this narrative that we've been seeing
over the last couple of rescues will
actually lead to something perhaps
around the recruiter because right now
it feels like Natalia just requested
that the black task run on in there and
grab whoever they felt they could easily
take away some have a settlement purpose
like Mari with her fish farm dock
Billings and potentially even Eva but
people like Mel and soon Jack I don't
really get it seems like more of a smash
and grab however I am looking forward to
vicr mik there could be something new to
learn here however Mel and likely Jack
I'm just not that enthused about anyway
what do you guys think thank you very
much for watching and extremist smallus
extremer
remedia
[Applause]
[Music]